بعدما اصبح يهدد الوظائف وحياه البشر اصبح
ايضا ينتحل اصواتنا انه الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذي احتل الساحه الغنائيه وبدا بالتدخل
في اصوات كبار المطربين واستنساخها الجدل
لم يتوقف منذ الكشف عن تقديم اغنيه جديده
بصوت كوكب الشرق ام كلثوم وانتهاء
بالعندليب عبد الحليم حافظ والقائمه قد
تطول الامر وصل الى قدره هذه التقنيات على
استنساخ اصوات مشاهير او حتى اصوات اشخاص
عاديين المعرضون للفكره قالوا ان ذلك
يعتبر تشويها لتاريخ الفنانين الكبار وقد
يعرض صاحبها للمسائله القانونيه وهذا ما
حدث فعلا مع ورثه ام كلثوم عبد الحليم
الذين طالبوا بمقاضاه الجهه التي استنسخت
صوتي الفنانين فيما اعتبر اخرون ان الصوت
من انتاج الذكاء الاصطناعي اما الكلمات
واللحن فليس ملكا للمنتج شاركونا هل انتم
مع ام ضد سن قوانين للحد من تطور تقنيات
الذكاء الاصطناعي